hallo
herzlich willkommen in meiner torten
wird wirklich zur fünften jahreszeit was
jetzt anders amira habe ich beschlossen
euch mein berliner setzte geben
also bei uns heißen zu berlin ja genau
warum zeichen für berliner in berlin
heißen sonnenschein scanner leopard ich
musste ganz leise sein du darfst gleich
wieder los
ich habe das ja schon bei facebook
angekündigt dass ich das machen werde
und ihr habt euch dieses rezept
gewünscht ich werde aber nicht wie bei
facebook angekündigtes thema fette und
bürger ansprechen aber dazu komme ich
nochmal später im video
der kleine leopard hier wird mir jetzt
dabei helfen genau und stadt zu zeigen
welches einmal die zutaten für den
hefeteig und zeigen dann ist weitergeht
für den hefeteig braucht ihr 500 gramm
mehl 200 milliliter mädels die iss war
aber nicht zu warm also so etwa 28 grad
ein würfel hefe zehn gramm salz dass ich
ein teelöffel ich gebe da noch etwas
abgeriebene zitronenschale mit rein 140
gramm butter ich habe jetzt hier
butterschmalz weil da eben mehr
buttergeschmack mit drin ist und 40
gramm zucker
zuerst nimmt ihr jetzt die hefe und
löste in der mönche auf meine war vorher
tiefgefroren und dann habe ich sie
aufkommen lassen und deswegen konnte ich
jetzt nicht hinein brüssel
aber wenn ihr frische hefe habt können
das einfach rein brösel jetzt gebt ihr
hier noch ein bisschen zucker mit rein
und so lasse ich das ganze ist einfach
kurz stehen bis die hefe ein bisschen
aufgehen kann
und dann werden wir gleich
weiterarbeiten so sieht die hilfe jetzt
nach etwa fünf bis zehn minuten aus und
die gebe ich jetzt hier direkt zur mehr
dazu und da können wir dann eben auch
erkennen dass eure hilfe gut ist unschön
aufgeht
ihr dürft ihr sich lediglich nicht so
heiß machen also nicht über 30 grad das
ist die beste temperatur und jetzt gebe
ich einfach alle zutaten hiermit dazu
das butterschmalz habe ich etwas
zulassen dass ich nicht zu heiß und noch
das ei und jetzt lass ich das ganze zu
einem richtig schönen glatten teig
verkneten
und wenn ihr dann merkt dass der teig
etwas zu trocken ist
gebt ihr noch bisschen milch mit dazu
und zwar hängt es mit der größe eures
eis zusammen und deswegen müsst ihr da
etwas aufpassen am anfang nicht zu viel
milch dazugeben und dann könnt ihr noch
bis etwa 30 milliliter dazu geben
den teig habe ich jetzt etwa fünf
minuten kneten lassen
das sollte auf jeden fall machen da mal
richtig schön elastisch wird auch der
klebt dann auch gar nicht und jetzt gebe
ich ihnen einfach auf meine
arbeitsfläche mit so einer tankkarte
geht es ganz gut
einmal noch mal kurz durchkneten und ihr
seht auch ich brauche kein mehl und kein
fett dazu weil er einfach gar nicht
klebt dann rollte den teig schön zu
einer kugel zusammen von außen nach
innen einmal umdrehen so geht es am
einfachsten und dann von außen nach
innen
den teig runterziehen dann nehme ich mir
mein übrig gebliebenes butterschmalz und
schmiert damit die kugel 1
damit sie jetzt gleich beim aufgehen
nicht austrocknet und jetzt wird der
teig abgedeckt und kommt an einen warmen
ort zum ruhen der sollte auch nicht mehr
als 30 grad haben und wenn er sich dann
verdoppelt hat werden wir dann gleich
sehen dank geht es weiter euch ist
bestimmt aufgefallen dass ich bei diesem
hefeteig weniger butter und weniger
zucker mitte teilt habt und zwar aus
folgendem grund ist einfach weniger
butter war ja sowieso die berliner
später in fett ausgebacken werden
und ich nehme weniger zucker weil dann
nämlich die berliner nicht so schnell
braun werden
deswegen müsst ihr hier etwas weniger
davon nehmen
und ich habe auch etwas weniger mensch
damit datei eben nicht zu weich wird und
das dann später zu schwierig wird die
berliner zu formen
ich las den teig jetzt etwa eine halbe
stunde für stunde gehen dann muss ich
auf jeden fall verdoppeln
und ich wusste da vorher auch nicht dass
man den teig nicht zu warm sagt also ich
wusste immer so bis 40 grad
aber anscheinend ist es viel besser den
teig nur bis bei 30 grad gehen zu lassen
und das werde ich jetzt und zeigt euch
damit weitergeht so jetzt habe ich hier
meinen teig da ist deutlich aufgegangen
was gehts richtig schön und der schau
richtig schön weich und die nehmen wir
jetzt hier heraus denn damit der teig
hatte den teig schön raums führen dass
ich auch ganz egal ob wieder zutrauen
gefällt ist da wo ich jetzt dem medium
eine arbeitsfläche leicht geht ihnen da
drauf und ihr seht da bleibt auch nichts
in der schüssel hängen und jetzt werdet
ihr die berliner formen und zwar werde
ich dir immer 50 gramm schwer machen
netze also hier mit der tankkarte
abtrennen ich weg dann immer noch gern 8
könnte aber auch nach augenmaß machen
aus diesem tag werden so etwa 18
berlinern stehen 250 passt also genau
und so könnte es jetzt erstmal
portionieren
zwei mädchen blech zurechtgelegt nicht
zu einer dauer pforte und etwas mehr
drauf einfach damit ich jetzt hier
gleich die rechnung dann nochmal sehen
lassen kann und dass sie das ähnlich
drauf ich habe jetzt übrigen 16 berlin
aus an ihrer hat einen und ich habe
einen kleinen rest dass ich aber gar
nicht schlimm weil damit kann ich dann
später eben die temperatur des fettes
auch mal messen jetzt nehmt ihr euch
einen teig und von denen zu einer kugel
zusammen immer von außen nach innen dazu
nehmt ihr euch den tag legt ihn so in
ihre handfläche und dann kommt der tag
von außen nach innen wird von außen nach
innen gefaltet wird es mit mehreren
fingern macht sieht es ebenso aus so
bekommt ihr die kugel hin immer von
außen nach innen von außen nach innen so
dass ihr hier in der mitte irgendwann so
eine kleine knoten habe das drückt da
einfach alles schön zusammen
und jetzt wird's in den handflächen
gerollt so bekommt er gleich eine
gleichmäßige kugel da können wir ruhig
bissle fester drücken ist darf auch erst
mal normal sein und dann die kugel und
dann werdet ihr mit den handflächen auch
immer runder
ihr könnt es aber auch super auf der
arbeitsfläche rollt mit der hand einfach
über den teig das geht meiner meinung
nach einfacher da muss man auch von
außen die finger ansetzen und dann holt
man und werden rollen geht der ganze tag
und bereit
und so legt es ihr dann auch das mähen
dafür eben auch dieses backblech können
sie leicht flach drücken und so findet
es jetzt mit alle machen das blech voll
ist und dann lassen wir sie gleich noch
mal gehen aber ich halte euch nochmal
vorher
du kannst die schlange fertig
mit beiden händen sitzt abt zwei kugeln
ich habe jetzt die erste portion fertig
die ersten neuen die decke ich jetzt
wieder ab und gibst du dann wieder in
meinen warmen ofen der hat wie gesagt
nur etwa 30 grad
und da müssen sie jetzt noch mal
mindestens eine stunde gehen ist sie
einfach richtig schön fluffig sind um
aufgefangen sind das ist nämlich auch
das was viele leute falsch machen wenn
die berliner selbst machen dass sie die
berliner nach dem formen nicht so sehr
auf gehen lassen und dann sind sie eben
sehr kompakt und sie neben nicht so
frisch wie die gekauften berliner ihr
könnt statt dieser rolle methode die
berliner auch also diesen teig ausrollen
und mit gläsern ausstechen
aber ich finde diese methode mit dem
bändchen viel besser da werden die
berliner schön und ich zeige euch dann
wie sie nach dem aufgehen aus meint
alten satz richtig schön aufgegangen
jetzt werden die berliner noch in der
friteuse oder im topf frittiert ich habe
eine friteuse was leider wir machen
einfach so selten was in der friteuse
dass ich denke dass ich für mich eine
anschaffung nicht lohnen würde
wenn man außerdem so geizig und ich weiß
jetzt im topf machen falls er auch keine
fritteuse hat zeige ich euch wie etwa
ungefähr die temperatur messen könnt
perfekt ist es natürlich wenn ihr einen
tachometer habt das habe ich jetzt aber
auch nicht also gehen wir jetzt einmal
nach gefühl
aber falls ihre friteuse oder ein
thermometer habt sollte das feld etwa
160 grad haben und nicht mehr weil
ansonsten die äußere schicht verbrennt
und ihnen der berliner hoch bleibt so
ein frittiert benutze ich jetzt
frittieröl da könnt ihr aber auch ganz
froh sonnenblumenöl nehmen
auf jeden fall muss das öl sein was man
eben starten kann
bis 160 grad wobei es ja so eine
mittlere temperatur ist es halt auf
jeden fall genug fett in eurem kopf
haben damit ihr berliner richtig schön
drin schwimmen kann
ich zeige euch jetzt die fertig
aufgegangenen rohlinge und zeigt dann
wie ich sie tiere hier habe ich jetzt
also meine teig rohlinge und hier mein
warmes fett und zwar ist bei mir so auf
meinen herd bis 9 geht und ich habs
jetzt auf stufe sechs und da müsste
jetzt auch mal umrühren und wenn ich den
holzlöffel reinsteckt bilden sich
bläschen drumherum
und es sollte so etwa 160 grad haben mit
einer friteuse geht es wie gesagt am
besten
die taiko ohlinger gebe ich jetzt daheim
lass dir ganz kurz anpacken und dann
werde ich ja auch gleich wieder umdrehen
jetzt gleich umdrehen und erst die
unterseite backen und dann die oberseite
fertig backen
und wenn sie dann so eine hellbraune
farbe haben wenn sie umgedreht und
fertig gebacken
und dann können dass sie herausnehmen
und etwas abtropfen lassen
meine bilder sind jetzt ausgebacken und
ich habe sie leicht abkühlen lassen
viele fragen mich dann auch immer noch
was ich mit dem altem frittierfett mach
ich habe jetzt frittierfett genommen und
werde diese sind abkühlen lassen auf der
flasche steht auch darauf dass man das
mehrmals benutzen kann wenn man es
vorher fehlt hat das heißt ich könnte
das jetzt durch so einen h7 durchziehen
lassen und dann wieder in die flasche
zurück geben und das noch 23 mal
benutzen das man bei anderen fetten
würde ich das nicht machen weil sich
durch die starke erhitzung eben auch
giftstoffe entwickeln können und
krebserregende stoffe
da würde ich die fächer nicht so oft
benutzen falls ihr die fed jetzt also
entsorgen müsst gibt sie auf keinen fall
in den abfluss das sorgt nämlich dafür
dass in den richtig schönen öl
schutzfilm um eure rohre drumherum habt
und es stinkt ganz gewaltig aus dem
abriss und außerdem kriegt dass er
schwer sauber außerdem noch das
würzburger und ich wirklich gar nicht
gut für die um herrlich deswegen solltet
ihr falls er vertrete hat diese am
besten in der tüte führen nach dem
abkühlen natürlich oder in eine
plastikflasche zurück fühlen und könnte
sie dann in den wertstoff müll geben
oder falls es bei euch auch ein
örtlicher abfallsammelstellen gibt könnt
ihr jetzt auch dort abgeben also da gibt
es mehrere möglichkeiten aber auf keinen
fall das öl in den abfluss oder in die
toilette gießen das ist nämlich gar
nicht gut und die workshops sammelstelle
hat die nehmen das auch kostenlos an als
treffen bezahlen falls dir öfter mal was
frittiert können das ja auch daheim
sammeln und dann irgendeine in der woche
oder einmal im monat da hinfahren und es
eben abgeben und dann haben alle ruhiges
gewissen und es wird richtig schön
umweltfreundlich entsorgt und jetzt geht
an das befüllen der leckeren berlin
na oder krapfen und zwar werde ich hier
für einmal laminate nehmen da habe ich
die von schwartau die schwarze samt ohne
kerne ohne stückchen gibt es aber auch
von anderen marken und ich habe ja auch
nutella das werden wir das machen
man kann die berliner natürlich mit
allem füllen beispielsweise auch eine
kleidung gehört oder mit eierlikör das
stelle ich mir auch ganz lecker vor
ich werde jetzt einmal zeigen und zwar
habe ich jemanden spritzt heute mit
seiner füllt töne den weg dafür setze
ich euch natürlich unten in der box sei
info steht einmal drauf drücken und da
findet ihr alle produkte mit rennen
da habe ich jetzt übrigens den mittleren
adapter und ich habe es gestern ja auch
schon gemacht deswegen habe ich da die
tür noch drin kann uns einfach
einstellen
man weiß einfach weiterführen und mit
dieser fülle dem übrigens etwa marmelade
und diese waldfrucht nicht immer überall
schmeckt mir interessant in berlin mit
dieser fülle könnt ihr es auch an dritte
führen also ops kronach sind oder ob es
vielleicht eine torte ich das habe ich
neulich auch gemacht eine orangen torte
und hab außen dann im kathrein gefilmt
ihr könnt damit trac-x und muffins
befüllen also da gibt es wirklich viele
einsatzbereiche für die erdöl- und
benutzten zugedreht
da nehme ich mir jetzt jemand ihnen da
und stellt von der seite rein dann
stelle ich das einfach hier rein bis zum
anschlag und drückt dann eben nach
gefühl marmelade rein und so macht ihr
das jetzt einfach mit allen anderen auch
und beim hotel arbeite ich so machen
dass ich das nutella in einem kleinen
gefäß in der mikrowelle etwas
damit eben etwas flüssiger wird aber es
darf nicht ganz flüssig werden weil so
ein schritt ist bespritzen auch ganz
schwierig und dann kann ich das auch die
gleiche methode einfach da rein spritzen
wenn ihr die berliner dann soweit
gefüllt habt könnt ihr sie mit etwas
puderzucker bestäuben
da es jetzt so das ja eigentlich diesen
schnee diesen staubzucker nehmen sollte
den auch die bäcker benutzen
den gibt es auch bald in meinem shop
aber weil es ähnlich hat mit normalem
zucker
nur müsste eben da euch bewusst machen
dass man der puderzucker nach einer
gewissen zeit drauf schmilzt und
deswegen wünschte ihnen erst kurz vorm
servieren drauf machen
ihr könnt aber auch ganz gerne zu
übernehmen und die warme berlin auch in
zimt zucker wälzen
das finde ich auch ganz lecker da sollte
aber nicht zu viel nehmen weil ansonsten
recht ein zuckerschock
und so sehen dann die fertigen berliner
auf und zieht sich eben nun mal so dass
ein selbstgemachtes alina die sehen
nicht alle perfekt aus und ich hab mich
jetzt wollen auch ein paar vage ärger
sind oval wurden oder so wie hier in
seine nase hatten aber deswegen sind wir
selbst gemacht dass ich ja gar nicht
schlimm
der perfekte berliner möchte muss ebenso
bäcker gehen das mache ich eigentlich
auch am liebsten weil dann meine küche
nicht so nach frittierfett stinkt wie
gesagt frittieren wir eigentlich ganz
selten war es gab 14 1 könig aber ein
gutes hähnchen zum beispiel schmeckt
eben frittiert am besten
und wenn ich dann mal ganz selten was
frittieren muss dann mache ich das eben
ansonsten berlin ist sich gern bei
unserem weg hat dann noch die selbst und
dann macht es elfer und aber selbst
gemacht sind sie natürlich auch ganz
toll eine wette ich jetzt mal
aufschneiden um geld das foto für euch
und natürlich möchte ich euch zeigen
erinnern aussieht also um geführt hat
ich vergesse zu fühle egal
das zeige ich euch jetzt auch wie schön
ruppig die sind das war absicht ich ja
so schön flug ist gut jetzt scheinen mit
füllung auf da könnte richtig schön die
leckere füllung sehen und wie fluffig
diesen und schön knusprig außen
rundengleich innen drin und die riechen
gut nach malate nach hefeteig
ich muss ein foto machen da nicht
reinbeißen
die berliner sind richtig schön der
kraft ich nicht trocken und ich find
waldfrucht marmelade pasta am besten
rein weil die einfach schon von business
säuerlich ist aber auch süß und ja ich
war mit langen schmeckt es auch richtig
gut vielleicht auch mit branchen-
füllungen
ich habe ja bereits vorhin gesagt dass
ich das thema fette und öle häute nicht
behandeln werde
das wollte ich aber nicht vergessen
sondern einfach nur in ein anderes video
mit einplanen
da ist einmal daten sieht unterwegs ich
habe im moment etwa eine reichweite von
einer halben million zuschauern im monat
so oft welt meine videos angeklickt und
ich bin ganz stolz drauf das ist
wirklich immer mehr werden pro monat
und da erreicht es natürlich ganz viele
menschen und bekomme wirklich jeden tag
ganz viele e mails
ihr habt mir auch jederzeit schreiben
ich bemühe mich immer darum alle e mails
zu beantworten
und da hat mich vor ein paar monaten
eine ganz herzzerreißende e mail
erreicht ich hab die leiter nicht
gespeichert deswegen muss ich jetzt
heute vorlesen weil ich diese eine
person wieder erreichen möchte weil ich
einfach vergessen habe ihre daten zu
speichern
hatte aber die e mail gottseidank kannst
du diesen e mail inhalt weiter geschickt
sodass jetzt den inhalt habe aber oder
e-mail-adressen bisschen blöd aber ich
denke ich erreicht sie ich lasse euch
einfach mal vor und dann sage ich euch
noch was dazu
sli ich gucke deine videos schon seit
mehreren wochen und freue mich immer
total will eines von ihr kommt ich habe
seit dem achten lebensjahr jetzt kommt
und wort ich kann's nicht aussprechen
alopecia areata das ist eine krankheit
wo die haare ausfallen und daher trage
ich da ich mich ohne unwohl fühle
und das im alter von 15 jahren nicht so
einfach ist eine perücke
zudem wurde vor drei jahren festgestellt
dass ich so lucky hab also
glutenunverträglichkeit und das ist
ziemlich schwierig für mich den getreide
kommt so gut wie überall form
nachdem ich einen kanal gefunden habe
habe ich angefangen
glutenfrei zu packen und meine mutter
und ich haben uns eine torten
zeitschrift gekauft und backen da
regelmäßig seitdem backe ich so gut wie
täglich denn beim backen kann ich
ausschalten und meine krankheit für ein
paar stunden vergessen und mich nur dem
rezept widmen das gibt mir kraft und
eine so positive art fair total auf mich
ab und ich werde richtig glücklich ich
war mir deine rezepte richtig gerne denn
sie sind so unglaublich einfach und
lecker und erklärt das so toll dass man
eigentlich gar nichts falsch machen kann
letztens haben wir probiert lebkuchen
männer zu backen
leider hat das überhaupt nicht
funktioniert und sie sind komplett
auseinander gelaufen und gar nicht erst
aufgegangen
auch hefeteig willkommen wir nur sehr
schwer hin und ich wollte dich fragen ob
du eventuell sich damit auskennt und
einen tipp geben kannst denn ich habe
alles so gemacht wie in deine videos
arbeite hefeteig wartet hat gelegt und
gar nicht so weich und fluchtweg wie in
seinem video
es würde mich freuen wenn du mir amtes
liebe grüße und an den armen und zwar
nicht so dass ich eben per e-mail ganz
viele themen angesprochen also da werden
ganz viele themen angesprochen
zur zeit bekomme ich viele e-mails
gerade über diese zöliakie über die
glutenunverträglichkeit viele fragen
auch nach wegen diabetes oder wegen
laktose-intoleranz was wir daneben
können was wir austauschen können und
diese e mail hat mich eben damals
erreicht und ich hab dann auch mit
meinem hersteller gesprochen und wir
würden diese mädchen auch gerne helfen
uns da ich leider deine e mail adresse
nicht mehr hat würde ich dich darum
bitten dass du mehr noch mal eine e mail
schreibt an info erzählt ist orten
welt.de die e mailadresse poste ich auch
unten nochmal rein in die infobox und
zwar bekommst du von meinem hersteller
und von mir einen bug starterset
geschickt und ich werde jetzt in zukunft
auch mehr auf das thema blut frei auch
mal
gehen hat bei diesem hefeteig wird es
wahrscheinlich nicht geklappt haben weil
man einfach wenn man dieses mal daneben
austausch noch mehr flüssigkeit benutzen
muss das sind andere verhältnisse die
man beachten muss
da werde ich euch demnächst auch mal
videos dazu machen weil ich einfach auch
wichtig finde dass gerade wenn man den
lebensmittelunverträglichkeit hat dass
man auch damit umgehen kann und auch
aufgeklärt wird
auch in der schule mit meinen schülern
so also ich habe eine zweite klasse
leute in der zweiten backen und kochen
wir auch ab und zu aber gerade in meiner
neunten klasse ist dann auch so dass ihr
dafür verbraucherbildung machen wir
gehen auch verschiedene themen ein
was sind vettel was sind was sind gute
marge was ist das das ist den
geschmacksverstärker und gerade da finde
ich es eben wichtig dass ich euch ist
auch eben bei euch das auch
thematisieren kann und ansprechen kann
und ich finde auch ganz wichtig gerade
so im sinne der nachhaltigkeit dass man
eben gerade jetzt mit diesem fed
beispielsweise dass man da eben dann
frittierfett nimmt dass man das öfter
benutzen kann und dann auch
umweltgerecht entsorgt und so themen
möchte ich jetzt demnächst ansprechen da
hab ich mir jetzt gedacht dass ich
sonntags jetzt immer so eine rock video
mache so ein ganz normales und unter der
woche mittwochs würde ich dann gerne so
ein bisschen eben verbraucherbildung
machen aber eingebettet in ein rezept
video also wenn so wie beim letzten mal
hatte ich auch die süßkartoffel haben
ein rezept gezeigt und dann eben auch so
ein bisschen verbraucherbildung
warenkunde und es würde ich jetzt gern
regelmäßig machen dafür west als schön
wenn ihr mir auch ein paar themen
schicken könnt ihr euch gerade bewegen
vor silvester hatte ich beispielsweise
zahlt zwar nichts mehr kochen und backen
zu tun aber das finde ich genauso
wichtig könnte auch im bereich gehört
auch zum bereich haushalte
textilunternehmen
da hatte ich vor silvester familias
kleider aussortiert und zwar mit ein
riesen wäscheberg und einiges habe ich
auch damals gespendet aber beim spenden
würde ich immer ein bisschen vorsichtig
und da will ich euch gerne nächste woche
mittwoch mal ein video dazu zeigen ich
bin dann nämlich auch eine ganz tolle
firma aufmerksam geworden und unendlich
die und falls ihr da auch schon ganz
gespannt sein das interessiert euch ganz
bestimmt auch würde ich mich freuen wenn
die da mittwoch einschaltet da drehe ich
dann wieder mit dazu dass auch ein ganz
interessantes thema ich was ich auf
jeden fall auch thematisieren möchte ist
es lebensmittel kennzeichnung gesetz und
zwar habe ich da eine seite entdeckt
erst foodwatch und ihr habt mal
aufgedeckt was so alles nicht alles
leider was ebenso in lebensmitteln drin
steckt und zwar ist bei uns in dem
lebensmittelgesetz so dass es ziemlich
viele lücken gibt und es gibt den firmen
geben die rechte dass sie nicht alles
immer kennzeichnen müssen wie sie es
eigentlich sollten
und ich find's als verbraucher sollte
man wissen was in der produkt drinsteckt
wenn ich beispielsweise eine
tomatensuppe kaufe was ich nicht machen
höhere weil sie selber auch
aber wenn ich jetzt eine tüte kaufe und
ich bin beispielsweise vegetarier
hauslehrer minute veganer nicht achte
vielleicht nicht auf die inhaltsstoffe
dann ist es ganz schön schlecht weil da
nämlich schweiz mit drin ist und ich
meine wer erwartet schon speck in einer
tomatensuppe
oder wenn ich mir überlege wir essen
abends auch mal beim filmabend mal ganz
gerne chips wenn ich da die falsche
marke kaufen kann es sein dass da eben
auch tierische bestandteile drin sind
wie wild und schwein das möchten wir
auch nicht unbedingt haben oder wenn ich
den frischkäse kaufe und auch nicht auf
die marke achte kann sein dass das
relative enthalten ist was natürlich
wieder für vegetarier
muslime und so weiter das passt
natürlich alles nicht und da will ich
auch ganz gerne ein paar videos mit
anbieten wie man als verbraucher etwas
aufmerksamer sein kann und eben einfach
so ein bewusstsein dafür entwickelt was
man lesen muss was man vielleicht auch
mal nachschauen muss und so würde ich
eben gerne verschiedene themen
aufgreifen beispielsweise in fertigen
sahnetorten ich auch schneller tine drin
und sich auch nicht immer so
gekennzeichnet oft ist es ja dann auch
so dass beispielsweise speise gelatine
dransteht viele wissen gar nicht dass es
dann ausschließlich von schweinen
hergestellt wird oder wenn ich gerade
diese katjes jo ganz anschaue da habe
ich auch einen beitrag dazu gelesen da
äußert sich die firma nämlich nicht dazu
aber anscheinend auch tierische
bestandteile mit drin und wenn ich mal
so an die merken denke so dieses baby
und vegetarisch und vegan
das passt einfach alles nichts zu sagen
und dafür nicht muss man aufklären und
dann müssen die verbraucher auch mal
aktiv werden und sich da eben
weiterbilden und das ist so
ich finde es sich jetzt um eine aufgabe
das mit euch gemeinsam zu machen und das
eben alles zu thematisieren
da könnte ich mir zum beispiel auch ganz
gut vorstellen gewisse firmen mal
anzusprechen anzuschreiben ich will auch
meine kamera einfangen und einfach mal
hinfahren
wir sind eine große fangemeinde wir
haben ja über eine halbe million klicks
und da finde ich kann man das wirklich
nutzen denn ich glaube die firmen sind
sich dessen meistens gar nicht so
bewusst was eben verbraucher alles
bewirken können
einige haben beispielsweise schon die
kritik von dieser webseite aufgenommen
und haben das dann umgestellt haben dann
praktisch auf vegetarisch umgestellt ich
finde es nicht schlimm wenn es drin
steckt ich finds nur schlimm wenn es
nicht drauf steht weil in street steckt
ist es nur eine sache dann kann ich
immer noch entscheiden als verbraucher
möchte ich jetzt diesen joghurt mit
gelatine oder nehme ich jetzt den
joghurt ohne gelatine
aber ich finde es muss einfach drauf
stehen das ist ja genauso beim textil
kennzeichnungs gesetzt wenn ich jetzt in
mein pullover reinschaut steht da
vielleicht medien germany drauf aber am
ende
nur der knopf oder die nato das etikett
auch nur in deutschland angeht
das sind eben zusammen was eigentlich
die politik betrifft weil die das ja
möglich machen diese gesetzeslücke
aber ich denke dass wir auch ganz viel
bewirken können und wenn ihr dieses
berliner rezept nach lesen wollt könnt
ihr das gerne auf meinem blog ton auf
www.starbett.de ich freue mich wie
gesagt auf eure rückmeldungen zum rezept
aber auch auf die themenvorschläge und
die wünsche im bereich eben
verbraucherbildung es muss nicht immer
was mit der küche zu tun haben finde ich
weil ich finde so ein haushalt da gehört
alles mit dazu und es gehört alles mit
zum gesunden leben
jetzt möchte ich das video gar nicht
weiter erweitern am mittwoch bekommt ihr
wieder mehr
ich werde versuchen für morgen noch ein
linzer torten rezept zu machen weil ich
auch ganz gerne esse und ich wünsche
euch auf jeden fall noch einen ganz
schönen tag und sehen uns bald wieder
zusammen
und vergesst nicht mal wieder zu
bewerten